Olympic skateboarding features two disciplines: park and street.
Skaters will have three 45-second runs on a hollowed-out park course...
...featuring a complex series of twists and turns.
Skaters gain points by performing spins and tricks midair...
...and then gracefully bring themselves back down to the bowl...
...to do it all over again on the other side.
The street competition features a straight course with stairs,...
...handrails, benches, walls and slopes to mimic a real street.
This kind of skateboarding is characterized by riding along curves and rails...
...leading into the air without using hands...
...and that familiar grind of board on metal.
Skaters will have two 45-second runs to show off their skills.
Judges will score athletes based on speed, difficulty, originality, stability,...
...and the overall flow of the performance.